but i tried harder vietnamese phrasebook
and listening and listening to material
for a few weeks and stuff but still in
vietnam it was unusable hi there steve
kaufman here today i want to talk about
language immersion and travel and how
that affects language learning
uh remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the bell for
notification
and if you're listening on a podcast
whichever podcast it is please leave a
review i do appreciate it
also i decided today you know i always
have my door closed
and people are interested in my book
collection and sometimes in behind but i
also have my cd collection
uh which no longer is relevant because
you can download so much audio content
from
the internet but there was a period when
i would be you know i'd go to riga
latvia to buy russian cds i would buy
swedish cds in sweden and chinese cds in
beijing and and and check cds in prague
and so forth
uh whenever i traveled one of my goals
was to stock up on
books or
or cds that weren't available at home so
that i can then go and listen and read
and i'd have you know available
reading material that was also available
in audio format all of that has changed
now because we can get digital content
uh to read
import into link
look up words and phrases and we can get
the audio content which we can download
and we can merge with it so there's so
many more ways to get that contact with
the language
but getting back to my door being open
sometimes people comment on my books i
just wanted to show you that there are
bookshelves in the next
sort of area corridor area there's a
guest bedroom over there that's got more
books in it
downstairs there are four more
bookshelves
with
books on various subjects so books
are a big part of my life always have
been i enjoy going back and discovering
old friends and
books are also a part of sort of
immersing oneself in the language i also
do read in english but if i'm reading in
a foreign language i've always found
that reading a book is just it's just
getting that language in you it's just
immersing yourself in the language
and and audio books do that and books
that we read do that because
actually to improve in the language you
just have to get it in you expose
yourself to it now
obviously a great way to immerse
yourself in the language is to go to the
country where the language or to a
country where the language is spoken
and how does that best work well
my experience has been
that to take full advantage of doing
that you have to have a certain level i
would almost say like a b1 on the
european scale you have to have put in
at least six three to six months with
the language so that you can take
advantage of being in the country where
the language is spoken so you can
actually immerse yourself in the
language so let's take the example of a
line of a country where uh you know i i
visited and had no language
preparation let's say or minimal so that
would be say in my recent travels
myanmar and vietnam so i tried i bought
a little book on learning burmese
and i had essentially nothing
uh and and i came away with the uh gosh
i can't even remember it uh the word for
thank you and hello but that was about
it but i tried harder vietnamese
phrasebook and listening and listening
to material for a few weeks and stuff
but still in vietnam it was unusable
i could use my phone to dictate
something in english and out comes the
vietnamese and show to the person but
essentially it was not enough and so
being in vietnam
listening to vietnamese on television or
being surrounded by people speaking
vietnamese essentially did nothing for
me i would have been better off staying
at home
and listening to material for which i
had some text maybe beginner material
even phrase books hearing them over and
over again in sort of a concentrated
fashion being in the country didn't do
anything for me
okay now let's step up a bit and let's
go for example no and i could add to
that
israel when i visited israel i had even
put more effort into my hebrew and it
was hopeless i just wasn't at a level
where i could use it or take advantage
of the hebrew around me and in israel
you can speak if it if it isn't russian
first of all english and if they don't
speak english they'll speak russian and
in some cases they speak french so there
was no need to use hebrew it only became
a problem when i was trying to get my
car out of a parking garage and all the
instructions were only in hebrew and i
was lost i had to ask someone
but not in hebrew i have to ask them in
english or in russian or something
so that was hebrew
and then of course from israel i went
into jordan where
again i didn't have arabic but if i went
there now i would be better off i could
perhaps take advantage even though i
learned standard arabic i would be
picking up on some things from their
i guess jordan jordanian or levantine
arabic
so that's better
before going to romania and before going
to greece i put quite a bit of time
romanian of course is a lot easier than
greek because romanian is written with
the latin alphabet
romanian is 70
identifiable very similar to
other romance languages in particular
italian
uh
has some 20 slavic type words in it
uh so it's a lot easier so two months of
romanian
was
you know helped me a lot
and i was able to organize in romania
first of all i met with we do business
in romania so i met with people there
who didn't some would either humor me in
romanian because they thought it was
kind of strange that uh you know a
canadian was learning romanian and they
were very kind and humory or
i rented a car and for five euro a day
in romania when i went there three four
years ago uh you got a driver
so i i didn't want to be driving in
romania and run into a horse-drawn cart
or something and
i had a driver for five euros a day for
five years a day i had a driver a guide
and a teacher so we spoke romanian for
five six hours a day as i drove around
the countryside that was wonderful in
greece
in crete which is where we were i had
enough greek that i could actually speak
to people i could speak to people in
restaurants
not a lot i couldn't engage in profound
conversations but i was able to kind of
take advantage of being there but it
wasn't i i wouldn't say that my greek
improved tremendously
just by being there because i didn't
have enough of it and greek is more
difficult because there are fewer you
know recognizable you know cognates if
you want
so it wasn't enough to really immerse
myself to really take advantage now
let's go to some other languages where i
have combined learning with then going
to the country so uh check i spent a lot
of time with czech czech was you know i
did check after russian oh i did go to
russia after my you know exposure to
russia i went to russia and i had link
members there that i met up with in st
petersburg
and in moscow and i communicated with i
stayed in these converted communal flats
and so i communicated with
with the lady you know the heavyset lady
that ran those places both in st
petersburg and in in moscow
uh and so i was using it and i was
operating and and i remember going to
saint petersburg train station to to buy
a ticket to go to v-berg where i had a
link member that i was going to meet up
with
and and again
buying a ticket i'm not asked to buy a
ticket i know how to i knew how to tell
her where i wanted to go but of course
she said something that i hadn't
anticipated so i was kind of thrown by
that but eventually i was able to
get across what it is that i wanted and
i got my ticket and that was good so
those 12 days in russia helped my
russian a lot so after russian it was
czech so i worked on my check did a lot
of listening told kiches coming lost
another great material on chesky rose
and then i had a tutor online in fact i
had two online tutors and i deliberately
set up with them that every day
first thing in the morning
i jumped on a tram i went to see the one
tutor
andre
and we were they spoke for an hour and
then i had another tutor in the
afternoon so that gave me
sort of additional because you can't
just approach random people i do that i
did that i sat in a restaurant there was
these two middle-aged ladies and i kind
of struck up a conversation but
there's a limit to how much of that you
can do
i also had some friends that i could
meet up with in prague so i kind of had
between my my two tutors and
being a little brazen about speaking to
people i did create
some speaking opportunities and of
course i could read the newspaper and i
could
if i'm listening or watching television
i would have enough check to take
advantage of that as an immersion
environment
uh so that was prague i set that up uh
when i went to
levive i had an online tutor and i sat
up with her
that
we would meet every morning so this is
actually a phenomenal thing to do if you
can do it in any city that you want to
meet or visit and it solomia was an
excellent tutor
and so she would meet me first thing in
the morning for coffee at nine o'clock
at this cafe in the uh
the square there
uh and we would speak
and then we'd go to her we'd go to a
church or a cathedral or if you know
there was a famous historical cemetery
or whatever it is we visited for five
days three hours in the morning three
hours in the afternoon
she had her iphone or android whatever
she had and she would write down all of
the words and phrases that i had trouble
with i'd go back to my little room at
noon
and i'd get her email which i would
import in the link and i would study
those words and phrases and we'd go back
at it again in the afternoon and i did
that for five days so i had a guide and
a teacher and not only a teacher but a
person who is giving me
the words and phrases that i struggled
with so that i could then learn them
again on link and i think i can imagine
you know i tried to do that when i went
to kiev i couldn't find anyone but if
you can have a guide like that who's
also a language teacher i think that's
another great way to and you know make
that immersion opportunity in the
country even more effective
and then the second time i went to
ukraine
i had people that i was meeting both in
eastern ukraine and western ukraine so i
was in situations where i was speaking
russian and ukrainian a lot so again
there because there were people in place
that were going to help make that
immersion experience you know genuinely
valuable and and i think i often hear
people say well you know i went to
germany and people only spoke to me in
english and of course this is going to
depend on which country you go to
in romania that's less of a problem
although the english level is not bad
there but if you go to germany or
holland a lot of people speak english so
you have to have a fairly strong level
in the language otherwise people are not
necessarily going to humor you people
don't want to be your language teacher
people
have things to do if you go into a store
and they sense that you don't
communicate very well in dutch or german
they will speak to you in english most
people some people may humor you but you
can't expect it so i've always taken the
approach that if i travel to a country
this just to summarize this around here
i should want you to be realistic about
how much you're going to benefit if you
don't have a sufficient level in the
language
even if you have a sufficient level it's
worthwhile trying to set up
people you can talk to
and as as i did in la viv and someone
said by the way as a comment on one of
my youtube videos where i was
not so positive on language schools
and this person said well you are very
positive about your experience at the la
viv
language and cultural centers language
school in la vie and of course i was
because solomia
accommodated my way of learning i don't
think i would have been as happy just
sitting in a classroom for six hours a
day so we got to make sure that we
structure
that time in the say theoretically the
immersion environment in a way that
works for you so for some people it
might mean going to school because
you'll meet people and the teachers will
certainly speak to you in the target
language and maybe some of the other
learners will so that's also a matter of
how you structure it for yourself but
there has to be some planning put into
it you can't just go there and assume
that by being in the country you're
going to come away
fluent in the language that has
certainly not been my experience so i
hope that's useful on this whole subject
of immersion and traveling to the
country where the language is spoken